the last 30 minutes of the auction
witnessed a rare phenomenon of
last-minute bids which skyrocketed price
of 69 million dollars people's
work also brought a new class of
collector to the century's old auction
house after 33
active bidders you had 33 active bidders
91
of them were new to christie's people
who know christie's they know christie's
but if 91 percent are new to christie's
they don't know christie's they just
came to christie's
and most majority were millennials and
gen x buyers
made up of made up the majority christie
said in a press release most bidders
were in the americas
followed by europe and asia so here's my
question i don't know if you know the
answer to this question
where most of your buyers or bidders
folks who are heavy or made their money
in the bitcoin world that kind of want
to be low-key and nobody knows meaning
are these art collectors bidding or are
they bit
exactly that's exactly they're crypto
people you're 100
right i got it they're absolutely crypto
people and so that honestly
and that was one of the first questions
when i came to this space like who the
hell are these people bidding on this
and
like why because this seems very
speculative
and it's like yeah it is very
speculative but these are crypto people
and if you made a lot of money in crypto
it's because you bet on crypto early
when it was quite speculative and it was
sort of like this bitcoin you know if
you made a bunch of money on bitcoin
it's not because you bought bitcoin you
know
three months ago it's but because you
bought bitcoin
10 years ago eight years ago when
everybody was like what is this stupid
crap this
is they're just paying for internet
money okay
great you're idiots and you were like
nah i'm gonna bet on
and you speculate it was it was not
anywhere proven at that time
and so now these people started
speculating on this
nft stuff and so that's where where it
is they are
new uh customers they are new people and
that's where i think this digital art
and nfts is going to bring in a massive
massive amount of new customers who
never thought of themselves as
collecting art
they look at art and it's like okay i
don't know what the hell that is
i don't give any [ __ ] about like what
that is it looks super weird
it doesn't connect with me at all i'm a
young guy
or whatever that made money on the
internet and sort of that does not speak
to me i don't know what it is i don't
really care about that
i'm not interested in buying that um and
so that's where i think this is going to
bring in a whole new group of collectors
um to to collecting art that that you
know
never would have thought of it before
and and that's huge for christie's to be
quite honest and it's huge for a lot of
this stuff
oh yeah absolutely there's those people
you know i hate to say it no offense to
them but like they're dying like they're
so old that they're dying
because it's old money but there's a lot
of new money out there there's a lot of
new money that made money on the
internet that's exactly it
and those people are gonna want art too
and that's where i think this digital
art is going to speak to them in a much
much more
sort of visceral way uh than the old art
did yeah i mean look
i think what is happening right now the
question then becomes can they convert
and sometimes the converting
takes a little longer right for others
to uh
say you know what this is the way to go
listen i don't care if you like it or
not the internet's here i don't care if
you like it or not
i know you don't want to post your
picture mom on facebook but everyone's
doing it
you know and now she did it everyone's
doing snapchat so
i think that has anybody weird contacted
you since the sale meaning an elon musk
or any of those has anybody
or the white house have you been in
contact with anybody
of extreme power that's like wait a
minute what the hell just happened can
you fill us in
on what you can say about nfts um i mean
i've talked to a lot of people before
that i talked to mark cube and i've
talked to gary vee
um you know i've talked to a bunch of
people who we are kind of like
what is going on here obviously i've
been on you know a ton of shows and
stuff
um but yeah i think it's honestly it's
it's still
so early in this that that people aren't
really understanding where this is going
or where it could go
um and i think it's it's very i think
at these prices too to be quite honest
it's almost very easy to
dismiss as like crazy crazy height that
it's just like well what is this come on
like there's no way it's worth that much
um and i think it it is very
um you know that there is some level of
like kind of like a bubble here
that i think it's it's there is you know
some level of like
and we're getting a bit jacked up here
but i i think it's
what i think what i would say to that is
there was a big bubble with the internet
and uh you know there was a lot of
people who are super jacked up about the
internet and they were paying crazy
crazy amounts of money
and then the bubble burst but the bubble
did not kill the internet
people kept using the internet because
the internet was useful and that is what
i believe will happen with nfts
i think it's going to be you're going to
see a bunch of people rush in and
okay nft of a toothbrush
nfg everything um but the technology is
is simple enough in a way and strong
enough in a way that i think it's going
to outlast that and all the crap's going
to get wiped out
and you know the amazons the googles the
blah blah blah they'll still be around
the beeples if you will but
you know what i mean i think it's one of
these things where people need to be
careful it is still very speculative
but it's it's something that i think is
going to be around for for quite a while
because it has a lot of use cases
and we barely barely scratch the surface
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye